[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sésame volant de la marine américaine
c'est la grande aventure qui commence
près de 4000 mètres de chute libre et
pendant une minute c'est le temps qu'il
leur faut pour effectuer leur descente
ils évoluent dans le ciel comme des
oiseaux des oiseaux un peu malhabiles il
est vrai
ce rendez-vous de l'espace n'est pas
aussi simple qu'il y paraît la caméra
qui suit les hommes volants trichent sur
la vitesse
elle tourne au ralenti
[Applaudissements]
les deux hommes tournois acrobatiquement
dans le ciel en filant vers le sol à
plus de 200 km à l'heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et si les parachutes ne s'ouvraient pas
[Musique]
ouf ça se termine bien quand même et
chacun des hommes volants atterrit
exactement sur la cible fixée avant le
départ
[Musique]
mettre le patrimoine artistique de
l'humanité entre toutes les mains c'est
le but de la nouvelle revue hebdomadaire
qu'on lançait au musée des Monuments
français du Trocadéro deux enfants ou
non célèbre pas le Mappy Casso et Aline
Cézanne une manifestation très
parisienne autour de 40 000 ans de chefs
à laquelle participait le Tout-Paris des
arts et le ministre de l'information
Monsieur Alain Peyrefitte
[Musique]
le tout New York s'est penché sur
l'avenir vestimentaire et VIP entendait
des personnages très importants ce sont
d'ailleurs ces personnages très
importants qui présentaient eux-mêmes
les modèles de la nouvelle collection le
printemps en complet classique Big Mac
grêle junior président de la Société
flagutika
Henri leking directeur du New York hors
magazine un vêtement de sport
je suis d'elle président des magasins
Kodak en blaser et pantalon de flanelle
rayé
[Musique]
essayez maintenant d'imaginer nos
présidents directeurs généraux
présentant eux-mêmes leurs modes
vraiment l'Amérique n'a pas fini de nous
étonner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en France les problèmes sociaux restent
à l'ordre du jour par deux fois quatre
heures de grève des employés de l'EDF en
privé Paris de courant et les carrefours
de feux de signalisation il en est
résulté un certain nombre
d'embouteillages
[Musique]
embouteillage rue de Rivoli ou les
fonctionnaires ont défilé de l'Hôtel de
Ville au ministère des Finances pour
réclamer eux aussi une augmentation de
salaire
[Musique]
à Marseille
2500 mineurs sont venus du bassin de
Provence pour manifester
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la grève des mineurs en était à sa
quatrième semaine et on attendait une
solution de la réunion des syndicats et
de la direction des charbonnages mais
les mineurs ayant jugé insuffisantes les
propositions qui leur avaient été faites
les négociations sont dans l'impasse
[Musique]
au Japon le printemps a mal commencé
pour la petite ville côtière de nous la
pluie et la fonte des neiges ont miné la
colline voisine et des tonnes de terre
ont déferlé vers la mer
à la sortie d'un tunnel un train a été
happé par miracle on a compté que si
blessé léger et de disparu alors que
certains wagons ont été transpercé par
des arbres
une soixantaine de maisons ont été
également détruites mais les habitants
de nous ont pris la chose avec
philosophie c'est toujours pareil au
printemps du style
[Musique]
il y a maintenant un an qu'à la table
verte de l'Hôtel du Parc les accords
d'Évian ont mis un terme au conflit
algérien mais au milieu des soubresauts
entraînaient la fin d'un tel drame une
partie importante de la population
européenne d'Algérie ne vit d'autre
issues que dans son départ
650 000 personnes partir pour la
métropole
plein des secours immédiats qui répondit
au désarroi du déracinement se trouvait
posé à plus longue échéance un problème
d'intégration d'une ampleur sans
précédent telle est l'opération
entreprise aujourd'hui par Monsieur
missof ministre des rapatriés
il s'agit de réaliser l'intégration à
l'économie nationale de 100 000
rapatriés ils savent bien tous que leur
dignité exige qu'il participe à la vie
active et nous se contente pas d'une
assistance qui serait nécessairement
éphémère
une telle opération n'est évidemment pas
facilité par la concentration spontanée
des rapatriés dans le Midi et n'a de
chances de réussite que par une
dispersion dans tout le pays 250
000 chefs d'entreprises ont su le 18
mars un questionnaire pour recenser les
emplois vacants qui entre le 8 avril et
le 1er mai seront tous bloqués au
bénéfice des rapatriés
c'est un fait que l'économie française
est actuellement en expansion partout de
nouveaux emplois se créent l'intégration
des rapatriés se présente donc comme une
chance supplémentaire de l'économie
cette économie a dit monsieur missof a
besoin de cette main d'oeuvre énergie le
problème des mutations géographiques
vers des régions en expansion concerne
tous les Français les rapatriés n'en
sont que les premiers acteurs et le pays
leur fait confiance
[Musique]
sous les brumes du Pacifique entre
l'océan et la Cordillère des Andes
s'étend un désert long de 2000 km seul
les fleuves descendants des montagnes
transforment tout à coup en campagne
verdoyante un paysage de désolation
et du nord au sud la route panaméricaine
traverse le Pérou elle longe une côte
inhospitalière dont l'étrangeait le
voyageur elle le conduit à travers le
temps au berceau de civilisation qui
sont encore des énigmes pour l'homme
moderne
[Musique]
c'est spectacle macabre ne sont que le
résultat de profanation perpétré par des
pillards qui la nuit ouvre des tombes un
violet depuis des millénaires pour y
prendre des bijoux des pierres
précieuses et même certaines poteries
recherchées par les musées de tous les
pays du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les corps des morts étaient à cette
époque comme en Égypte enveloppé de
bandelettes souvent tissée avec art et
un fruit dans ce désert aride ces mots
mis en traversé les siècles sans dommage
[Musique]
siècle d'oubli
des monuments élevés par ces peuples
inconnus il reste encore ses pyramides
d'argile séchées qui rappellent les
constructions babyloniennes
[Musique]
que dire de ces curieuses figures
géométriques que seule l'avion nous a
permis de découvrir il y a peu de temps
face au ciel elles offrent une
ordonnance rigoureuse et complexe qui ne
peut être que de la main de l'homme et
dont l'origine est l'utilité échappe
jusqu'à présent aux archéologues du 20e
siècle beaucoup ont remarqué
l'analogique elles affrêtent avec la
topographie d'un aérodrome moderne
invisible du sol révélé par la photo
aérienne elle furtignerait des nombreux
peuples qui vécurent là au cours de
l'histoire et notamment des Incas
l'homme moderne qui se croit le pionnier
de la conquête du ciel devra-t-il
admettre des précurseurs balises
aéronautique ou symbole astronomique
pourquoi ces créatures aux ailes
déployées gravées dans le rock et large
de plusieurs centaines de mètres
[Musique]
qui nous dira ce qu'on veut ces deux
personnages dans leurs auréoles
flamboyants
le même visage de lumière nous attend
sur la Porte du Soleil à tiwanako le
calendrier astronomique de la planète
Vénus est reproduit exactement sur ses
hauts reliefs et certains ont pu aller
jusqu'à conclure en découvrant ces
personnages volants et ses pistes
mystérieuses que dans ce coin d'Amérique
du Sud avaient autrefois vécu une
humanité venue d'un autre monde
[Musique]